so um next question do you guys know
what hypergamy is
no talk to me you know do you know what
hypergamy is
oh when a woman should date a man who
makes more money yeah
sort of
it's more like women want a guy that
they can like look up to in some way so
like for example an example where i'm
hypergamous is i wouldn't date a guy
shorter than me like so i want someone
taller than me right so that's hypergamy
um another example is making more money
um usually like a girl wants a guy
that's like better looking than her
typically is what like i'm describing is
hypergamy is that what you guys have
seen um in dating would you say that
girls are always on to the like the next
best thing i want come out to go for i
usually like to go after come outside i
might come out respectfully to go first
i feel like women
and society
they place values on certain things
money height etc etc which i don't
believe it's the right things but like
at the end of the day you know what you
want and what you want is what you want
so if you want a man that can provide
for you first of all
i'm never going to be like okay
you're doing too much let's say you're a
woman
you want a certain type of lifestyle
you're accustomed to a certain lifestyle
you say hey i'm not gonna date a man
that doesn't pay my bills this and that
hey i know
i can't afford that so i'm not gonna
talk to you but somebody will
pay for it somebody would take care of
you so that's fine as long as you know
you should do it
but don't be the type of person that
says oh i'm independent i'm this and
that that you need someone to provide
for you that's when i go okay
you're doing you're doing too much
you're contradicting yourself now right
i'm all about if you say something say
this what i like that's what i need
stick to it but don't place your values
and understand say i'm independent i'm
on this and that no you're not
go ahead okay so
this is why i said we want to get along
two leos
but like okay so what if i as a woman
and like i'm independent and i'm gonna
make my own but that's and that's fine
until i have children and i want to be
there and raise my children and i want
to be with a man that can provide for
the family until i can start working
again until they're of a certain age
to where they can be in school and like
you know i don't want a nanny or
like there's
let's and that's a whole nother thing
child care and
quality child care
i don't want somebody that i don't
really
trust and know and child care is very
expensive it's not affordable to raise
my children and so what if i don't want
to marry a man
that
maybe i make more money than him at
first but if i need to stop working
because a children needs their mother
more than their father and that's just
facts
they really do 9 months in yeah
yeah like when the baby is young it
needs the mother to be there to feed
them i mean and i'm talking more
personally breastfeeding like that's
what i'm thinking naturally defeated
trust me
natural immunity people i'm talking like
more like thinking of a motherly like
you have to feed your child every couple
hours
yeah like
would your opinion change when i'm
talking from that standpoint listen
when you're talking
to a man at that stage first of all it
depends on your age so you're in your
mid-20s you are not thinking about can
this guy take care of my kids isn't that
you're thinking about
oh
that's not driving me what's that she's
not trying to say that
i'll tell you right now it's not in her
mind she's talking she's like you're
talking to two women and you're saying
it's not in there first of all
my mom talks in my mind my mom taught me
don't have kids unless you can provide
for you yeah to others that's just how
my mom taught me because she's beautiful
she's a single mother she's raised
three boys by herself my mom always
tells us like you're gonna have kids
don't have kids this and that you're
gonna have kids make sure you can
provide for yourself and two others
that's why
i'm not really doing those things man
i'm jimmying up clearly your mother
raised you right
i'm not swimming without a life jacket
trust me
no love no love
that's just out but
so you don't think girls
think about that honestly they do like
women
what we do woman you take them on a date
and first of all they're anything about
the three kids they're gonna have what
they're naming them
i've done these scenarios in my head
with girls that i really like so i
already know they do that often they do
that way more than us but i must say i
don't believe that when you're talking
to a woman at that point they're like oh
this
no
what they like at that point if they're
that type of girl quote unquote like the
cloud they want someone that can provide
for them
they already know
what type of environment they're going
to be in they already know where to find
these men it's just it
they don't want to they're not looking
for no intellectual man no harry why are
you telling you i hear you this is how
it is women that are just looking for
like a step up like a like a free ticket
and that's fine yeah and that's fine if
that's your life so that's your
lifestyle because at the end of the day
is more so onto the man they already
know what type of woman that they're
dealing with
so
they're the women are playing the field
and
it's just it's on to the man to decide
okay am i gonna take this girl seriously
i might not and they already know like
if that girl is not in your lane you
already know it's gonna cost you yeah my
daughter's just not talking like that
yeah i'm not giving a deal there's
certain girls i'm gonna deal with it i
already know what's up yeah you already
know we're talking about yeah and that's
fine that's you can be attractive you
can do your thing but like i didn't do i
can't take you seriously in that sense
but you're not wrong for thinking oh
i don't trust this man
if i get pregnant
to you know take care of me and a child
it's all and women women do get the
short end of the stick and i do believe
that
you guys i do believe that you guys
should have those options in the sense
that
as soon as you get pregnant your career
goals everything takes a break so in
that sense you guys should have all the
options to control like what you want
and i'm always for that agreed because
what do you mean what do you mean all
the options like what do you mean by
that exactly what she's saying child
support and stuff like that who am i
going to talk to what kind of guy am i
going to talk to just because i know
that if i get pregnant today my job can
replace me to go on leave man doesn't
have to deal with the labor all that
all the effects of well
no i'm sorry
[ __ ] you
ouch wait damn wait hurry up
we ban anyone in the chat that insults
people on their looks that's not cool so
um i'm [ __ ] cute as [ __ ]
no they just that's how it's because i
don't like
white men so it's a it's definitely a
white guy though oh yeah i know 100
percent
you're a white man he messaged you no
well he's okay well no no
[Music]
i wasn't gonna read that comment
wait guys quiet for a second so the next
super chat i got could you date an
atheist or someone who doesn't believe
in soul mates or someone who's
completely different set of beliefs from
alex schmidt
um thank you for the donation
okay so
i would like to go first on this one
okay because i i went to channel the
next the last topic i couldn't but me
personally i couldn't at all okay uh
somebody's the atheist me
my family being